welcome back to the show everybody
remember that we are primarily funded by
viewers and listeners who sign up on my
website you can find the membership sign
up form very extensive form you put in
like your email and you make a password
um at
joinpacman.com the normal membership
rates i find to be really a great deal
but what the hell do i know um if you
don't like the prices though you can use
the code better 21 and get a discount
not means tested open to everybody you
decide you decide
let's hear from some people in the
audience so one of the best parts of the
week for many
uh a terrible part of the week for some
others okay right let's just get into it
it's via discord you can um participate
at davidpakman.com
slash discord let's start today
with caitlin from alaska caitlin from
alaska you were on the air
can you hear me okay i can hear you
beautifully katelyn yeah
perfect it's been a minute glad to hear
you're doing good i actually don't have
a question i just wanted to give you a
quick update here from alaska please um
since we made news with our
fantastically wonderful um
you know mass mandate discussion
um
uh oh caitlyn right as you were about to
get into the substance you glitched out
tell us again what's happening now in
alaska
i personally don't know anyone who's
passed away from covid my work is very
strict with our guidelines okay so no
one is allowed into our office without
being vaccinated
and even with that
we've had one person
catch covid
we've had two others who have been in
contact with somebody and had to
quarantine
um my sister is a hairdresser and she
sees
like a hundred people a week
and she's been lucky enough to not
catch covid right
so
it seems to me that even though alaska
is doing absolutely atrocious with
everyone i know
we're all very
we always wear our masks outside of the
house okay and so
it seems like for those of us here in
anchorage
as long as you still
continue with the mitigation efforts
along with being fully vaccinated most
people are safe
so
i the numbers are terrifying and i
really really wish we didn't have such a
ignorant mayor
but
i mean as long as people are intelligent
and use their brain we seem to be doing
okay
all right very good caitlin thank you
how many hours of uh daylight do you
have right now up there
um the sun's rising right now it's 8 12.
i would say it usually sets around six
or seven right now okay so it's starting
to become more a little more normal i
guess
normal for other people yes yeah very
good all right caitlin thank you always
great hearing from alaska
okay thank you caitlyn apparently
disappearing there very good well we got
our alaska update which is a great start